[Music]
[Applause]
look at that transition i'm getting
better and better at this
better and better at this whoa
boy did we have a lot of [ __ ]
boneheads this week now we just watched
some of the boneheads that we have um
they didn't make the list but we got we
had some of the boneheads on um this
press conference here
boy oh boy oh boy if i could put more
people on the list i would if i could
put all of the texas lawmakers that are
actually in office and don't have any
sort of empathy or care for human life
or just want to [ __ ] a gun
they would be on the list you mean they
got gun boners is that what they dude
they got guns in the front and guns in
the back door
the back door
speaking of back door a guy who who is
obsessed with back doors now he's
obsessed with back door reform his uh
senator ted cruz he made our list texas
attorney general ken paxton that pile of
[ __ ] he made our list and then the
biggest of them all uh governor greg
abbott the one who caused this tragedy
in uvalde that's right i said it
governor abbott caused this
he caused it
if you don't believe that you are
[ __ ] deluded you are kidding yourself
if you don't think that these lawmakers
made sure to pass laws to where this was
easier to happen
they have caused this they have blood on
their hands and not only that not only
that two of these [ __ ] that are
on this list are still going to go to
the nra and stand up and cheer
um as they [ __ ] piss on the
pile of dead bodies right
the 19 dead children and the two
teachers in uvalde texas they're going
to cheer yeah take this you can take
this from a cold dead hands
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] and so is the
former guy but these were our
contestants this week we felt like
that this was probably
the short list here of people who
not only could prevent this um [ __ ]
from happening but continue to
say stupid [ __ ] about back doors and
stuff and of course we've seen just seen
the clip of the uh law enforcement's
press conference it looks like they're
gonna blame that it looks like they're
gonna blame the teachers get it was
those teachers fault
i mean let's just run through the list
we're blaming video games right blaming
mental health but we won't do anything
about it okay so you [ __ ] you if you
have mental health right uh we are
blaming um [ __ ] back doors right
we're blaming wait what culture woke
yeah the [ __ ] wokers oh yeah right
wokers and those [ __ ] teachers
yeah you know at some point i bet you
republicans will say
it's the parents fault no no it's the
students
man if you're not fast enough to dodge
these bullets then you're just prior to
probably probably part of the cancer
culture and you know what you're just
trying to cancel that guy's right to go
in and slaughter children for crying out
loud it's part of cancer culture i mean
like they say right if you can dodge a
wrench
you can dodge a bullet that might be
that might be the case
these pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ] here they
aren't here's our um
our contestants this week the boneheads
of the week they all kind of [ __ ]
themselves right i don't even know
really where to start here
um of course we know that um ken paxton
he got short on the list which is kind
of surprising this guy didn't get hardly
any of the votes well you know i guess
when you're suggesting ideas
giving teachers guns is maybe the least
ridiculous thing in terms of comparing
it against back doors
and other things to blame right well
well let me see if i i just have to
assume let me see if i can find the clip
that you're talking about work impacting
because he was on fox news i believe
where he said this stupid [ __ ] where
he's gonna and i'm also i just wanna i'm
going to preview
the first uh maybe a couple minutes
of the what was that because it happens
to feature all three of these people
okay but i do it until ted cruz i'm
still editing but i at least wanted to
give people a taste because i've been
talking about it this week and i'll get
it out by the end of the day
um but you know here we go i got one
better for you here he is on newsmax oh
yeah a different trader tv network yeah
the news mecca you know yeah
newsmax get that [ __ ] out of here
of course ken paxton down here in the
ken paxton shirt
guys vote for me somehow i won my
primary even though i'm under federal
investigation and have been for some
time because i'm a [ __ ] criminal um
well let's see what at this point if you
see on the screen here it says 14
children one dead teacher so this like
they haven't even mopped up the bodies
yeah this is they haven't really checked
all the limbs that are this is
as at this point we believe this is the
number turns out we're wrong right right
and here's what here's what that the
great attorney general that [ __ ]
shitbox had to say
about the shooting let's listen as as
you well know the state of texas not a
stranger to shootings that either begin
in schools or wander into schools what
in the [ __ ]
not a stranger
oh well yeah this is familiar this is
familiar mr attorney general who is the
top law enforcement officer in the
goddamn state
we love it here in texas when people go
into schools and shoot and murder
children
how do you lead into someone to be like
hey we're going to take
my transition the transition on this is
like listen we're going to get your take
and obviously someone who has experience
with school shootings and mass shootings
in your state that should never be the
first thing you say to introduce someone
onto your show
but unfortunately they use it and they
say this is a good thing because you
have experience
these [ __ ] [ __ ] boxes
let's listen
uh i know your team has dealt with this
before what were some of the solutions
and i know that governor abbott and
lieutenant governor patrick have also
come up with tasks for task forces to
harden these schools so they're not easy
targets easy prey for crazy people who
go nuts with firearms
okay this whole hardened school thing
this is really [ __ ] dumb
this is really [ __ ] dumb like these
these these schools aren't even scared
of like tornadoes anymore in some of
these places they're more terrified and
do more drills
of a [ __ ] weapon coming into school
and murdering children and and teachers
than they do a tornado ripping through
their community and he's like yeah what
you put together tax forces to make sure
that this happens continually is that
what he's and that's what i hear him
saying yeah i mean what they're saying
is and he says it in another segment
which i feature in the video but uh that
i'll wrap up but
uh in this interview and the other one
they talk about obviously how they can
prevent it right but the reason they
need to armed arms is because they don't
have the resources
to stop it it's yeah i don't know man
it's almost like if you remove the guns
from the equation
you wouldn't need to have more people
in law enforcement to stop said
shootings or spend money on i don't know
hardening the schools maybe give them
[ __ ] pencils and erasers you [ __ ]
dummies
stop taking away their [ __ ] math
books what a bunch of [ __ ]
uh
what what can you tell us has been
talked about in the past what has been
implemented and what hasn't been
yeah sadly this has happened again and
it's it's a horrible tragedy but the
types of things that we talked about and
i'll never forget it after the santa fe
shooting it was having one point of
entry making
potentially teachers and other
administrators who have gone through
training who are armed because first
responders typically can't get there in
time to prevent a shooting or when they
do get there they're scared of being
shot as if a teacher so so what gabe i'm
i'm wondering i guess we're just going
to
all the teachers are going to have to
walk around and [ __ ] body armor yeah
and they have a semi-automatic rifle
slung over their back just in case this
[ __ ] happens because it sounds like
texas wants to make sure they harden
their schools where they have armed
guards not just at the door inside the
classrooms and really honestly to make
sure to protect those
those students from those woke-ass
teachers now that they're going to arm
them now that they're going to arm the
woke-ass teachers you're probably going
to have to make sure that students are
wearing flak jackets and they have their
own semi-automatic rifles yeah protect
themselves from the crazy ass mother
wokers that are the teachers trying to
teach them crt and [ __ ] this this this
nonsense and this delusion and this
[ __ ] just absolute vile dribble
does not stop and it's not going to
folks people like ken paxton shouldn't
even [ __ ] have his own t-shirt that
has his name on it okay
let alone being the texas attorney
general running for it and then getting
the nomination
listen if you if you are in texas and
you are hearing my voice right now go
fire these [ __ ] that is your
choice in texas that's your choice and
in any state really that is nonsense
like here in missouri we have the same
stupid ass [ __ ] that goes on at our
state capitol and continues to go on
about this gun [ __ ] and they continue to
scourge i'm sick of this [ __ ] i'm gonna
get him i i'm i'm done with him
[ __ ] ken paxton [ __ ] him all the way off
all the way the [ __ ] off [ __ ] this guy
with the doors and the [ __ ] giving
teachers guns and making sure they're
the targets you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
speaking of piece of [ __ ] let's move to
our next piece of [ __ ] garbage here
senator ted cruz
oh my god we don't have to very go very
far for this [ __ ] do we no you
just got to go through the back door
same [ __ ] [ __ ] with the back door we
just watched the [ __ ] [ __ ] with the
the the video
that uh that brent did about the back
door [ __ ]
this one slimy piece of [ __ ] now i'm
telling you this back door stuff we can
continue on this back door stuff but
this [ __ ] is gonna go he's gonna
go to the nra blood on their hands
gunless gathering tonight and he's gonna
blame that [ __ ] teacher for propping
open that back door he's gonna [ __ ]
do it
because he's a [ __ ] coward he's a
goddamn coward he won't [ __ ] pro
press the blame or the blame needs to be
pressed and it's it's in his own goddamn
pocket
that [ __ ] money that he's taken from
the nra that piece of [ __ ] trash
sorry i'm i'm a little no it's fine no
it's not i mean they're stopped they're
all pieces of [ __ ] uh if you're gonna
play that clip whenever you're gonna
play it i got the other video too
that features the back door yeah well i
i'm i'm not gonna play anymore back door
clips i will play this this is a video i
did this video last year last year i did
this video and i was like oh this sounds
pretty evergreen but i'm i'm sure this
is going to last for a long time as long
as ted cruz has any microphone to speak
into
let's listen to me from a year ago have
you ever noticed that republicans seem
to be in a competition of which one of
them can be more [ __ ] repugnant than
ted cruz
[ __ ] him i'm just i'm just saying it
does seem like a [ __ ] competition
with these guys trying to figure out who
can be more [ __ ] repugnant than ted
cruz ron johnson goes on a tirade this
morning about faith and morals and
wokers and all kinds of [ __ ] i mean
he really seems to be trying to out ted
cruz ted cruz it's [ __ ] gross
speaking of ted cruz you got a little
sample of what um
of what uh you wanted to play here let's
see we did there we go maybe
maybe maybe not i don't know what the
hell is going on here
and the stereotyping
what's going on i also loaded in the
other one so go to the
oh did you okay yeah well yeah well
maybe here we go okay are we getting it
maybe here i can see it tuesday may 24th
19. yeah it's not it's not that much
it's not doing what you want no this guy
this racket go to the other one go to
the other one did you load it in yeah
yeah here it is okay here we go on
tuesday may 24th 19 young children and
two adults were killed in a school
shooting in uvalde texas it took over 90
minutes to stop the shooter but it has
now been revealed that some police
officers breached the school to get
their own children out before
the shooter was taken down
[Music]
texas law enforcement officials have
changed their stories so many times i
wouldn't be surprised if we find out
they personally escorted the gunman into
the school this was the deadliest
american school shooting since the 2012
massacre at sandy hook elementary this
is the 27th school shooting this year we
have had 213 mass shootings in less than
six months of 2022. you don't need to be
enrolled in ron desantis school of band
mathematics to know how bad these
numbers are the uvalde shooting happened
just 10 days after the horrific shooting
at the buffalo supermarket on may 14th
we unfortunately live in a country where
guns outnumber people and gun violence
has become an everyday occurrence the
correlation between the number of guns
in america and the number of gun related
debts in america is undeniable maybe the
slaughtering of innocent children is a
wake-up call for republicans they are
the pro-life party after all and they've
said on multiple occasions they want to
save the children
so you know what i'm sure they have a
plan to fix this epidemic and prevent
future mass shootings i'm sure by now
texas senator ted cruz has offered a
solution one of the things that that
everyone agreed is don't have all of
these unlocked back doors have one door
into and out of the school i'm sorry
what was that
what what was that what was that oh man
thanks for the preview especially with
this with the with these boneheads now i
gotta move along here we are we are
getting to the bottom of the hour here
um
i guess i guess maybe we'll go to the
who's the who's the alpha cuck is that
the alpha cuck that we got this that's
albuquerque that alpha alpha clock alpha
wasn't the alpha cuck last week
he might have been i know he might have
been no i can't this guy this guy always
appears on our radar no actually i don't
think he was last week uh i think with
someone else but he was he was maybe the
week before that
um
but what is this
this week what happened gabe
you've done your research on this
because we talked about this the other
day yeah nick this week nick fuentes has
uh has become the alpha cuck for his
projection
and his hate
against himself
um
nick fuentes is someone who is a nazi
uh just gonna put it out there yeah and
it's it's not us we're not i mean he's
he's a proud nazi yeah yeah he
doesn't like anyone else that isn't
white that isn't straight
anyway what ends up happening is he
reveals a screenshot to prove some dumb
point that he has
turns out that in said screenshot
he shows the tabs
of the the websites that he's on because
he's trying to show his he's trying to
show his google numbers down here at the
bottom right and right when he's behind
the show yeah so in this
he's like all right cool got a
screenshot instead of taking a
screenshot of the actual page or i think
this might have been a video or
something and there's a screenshot that
was taken from it
but what we see here is there's a bit of
a
graphic image in the background there
right if we enhance
and look at what that photo is let's let
you know let me let me see if i can pull
that one up and see what that there it
is uh i don't know i don't know if
youtube allows us to put this up but i
don't give a [ __ ] and there we go yeah
so
look so there's a pho there's a there's
a video that he has loaded in his safari
tabs in the background there
and
it matches up with a
video
a sex video with a
with a trans person and which i mean hey
whatever suits your fancy i not gonna
again
watch whatever porn you want as long as
it's as long as it's legal porn you know
it's like right right yeah yeah i'm
completely fine with whatever porn you
want to watch as long as i mean you are
who you are and you're free to who you
are and and
you know if you don't feel uh
comfortable in your own skin yeah
i'm even i'm even for people uh watching
porn that that maybe they don't
um project that type of
um
feelings out in the open i'm i'm okay
with people being closeted by the way i
have no
i have no ill feeling to someone who
wants to remain that's your choice you
have the freedom in this country to have
the sexuality that you want to to
identify as you want that's your [ __ ]
freedom that's their constitutional
right as far as i'm concerned you got
the constitutional right to watch
whatever porn you want but this idea
that this [ __ ] basically calls
for the the genocide of a certain type
of people
and he may be that person it is it and
it's it's not just vile it's projection
and it continues to show you right it
continues to show you that this this
fascist ideology they really are they
really are frightened by their own
[ __ ] being by their own identity it's
[ __ ] weird i mean every attack and
accusation they have is just another
confession
well and you you can almost see it and
watch for it right like this this
[ __ ] where these cops down there in
uvalde are are
light-handedly blaming the teacher for
propping open the back door as if as if
that teacher her intent or his intent
whoever it was to prop open that back
door so that those kids would be
murdered you
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
i mean how long until we start banning
teachers tony all right well you know
they're trying they're just saying
certainly
they went for the books
next they're coming for the teachers
because the teachers
are who actually let
them a shooter isn't you know they they
let the shooter in and then they're the
cause for the mass shooting not the gun
not the the laws that allow this person
to easily buy a gun
but the teachers the teachers the
teachers who went out and got the got
the phone from their car propped the
door open
i'm telling you man i told you the other
day that they locked those [ __ ] back
doors i told you they lock them and nope
nope no they don't lock them the back
doors we need to ban back doors and all
this [ __ ] right
morons nick fuentes thank you for being
the alpha duck of the week you never let
us down i'm sure you'll make the list
somewhere next week oh yeah after
absolutely no way he's not going to make
the list oh no no
look he's been in the running before for
other parts he's been a you know
dishonorable mention he's been alphacut
he's run the
whole spectrum of stuff and [ __ ]
dirty violence and he will continue to
i'm sure absolutely well
i don't know what is it what his excuses
about um his self-hatred but i'm sure he
does have one i want to show you we we
have the dishonorable mention
uh you made lauren bobert the dishonor
was it after i sent you this video this
morning yeah yeah i was looking for
someone to put in there i think i'm
getting the video mj sent me this from
patriot takes yeah and um
i'm not gonna say the word that mj used
but um we decided not to make her alpha
cuck maybe another word another c word
in there but um we decided to you
decided to uh give her the the the great
honor of dishonorable mention yeah for
this video um in this video it appears
she's driving in the car and making a
video which
um is not is that seems illegal well it
seems
headed at a bare minimum
but you know you know she is a [ __ ]
bonehead that's why she's on the list
and she remains on the permanent list of
boneheads in my oh yeah but
marger taylor green are always on his
list also she says some really dumb [ __ ]
in this video which is not surprising
either because it is lauren bobert the
bobo the clown
oh let's see if we can bear through this
couple minutes here we go
bobo the count just bobo the clown
lauren bobert the dishonorable mentioned
bonehead of the week
so
i am on my way to carbondale colorado um
there's supposedly
an organized march the march for our
lives that's going to take place
and i'm really interested to see if
people know what they're marching for
she's such a [ __ ] idiot okay so so
she is she's making the um she's making
the
she's making the [ __ ]
uh assumption here that people who are
going to march
for the slaughtered people like actual
slaughter bodies the stacks of [ __ ]
children you know these people are like
save the children save the children
there's a [ __ ] stack of dead
children's bodies all over this country
and she's like i don't even know what
they've known what they're marching for
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] i'll say it
i mean i don't you use that word a lot
but when you're talking about marjory
tater green lauren brobert and folks
like marsha blackburn you just it it's a
perfect [ __ ] description
it really for someone to live in
colorado right you've got columbine
you've got aurora right right two
different events where somebody came in
and used a gun to murder people and then
you've got this person
lauren bobert who says
i'm showing up
for the march for our lives march
i wonder if they know what they're
really marching for
the [ __ ] lives
the lives it's a march for our lives
it's
[ __ ]
straightforward
it is the name it says what it is
it's for our lives
living
and those who were murdered
and she has the audacity to go i wonder
if they know what they're really
marching for all right
shut the [ __ ] up well i i can't shut her
up i got to play the rest of it gabe i'm
really i apologize but let's
let's hear what else this [ __ ]
bonehead has to say
um i guess this is
supposed to be
the beginning of people speaking out to
to take away
our second amendment rights
and i'm not i would love to stop it here
and have more commentary but i don't
know if i have enough time to [ __ ]
lay into this tweed happy about him
um
if this is really a march for our lives
let's march against abortion because i
was looking at statistics and there are
nearly 1
million
abortions per year in america
that is a bunch of [ __ ]
that's not even that's not even a real
thing
she literally she literally just went on
the website that she wanted that number
of went on reddit and like yeah that's
the truth it's a million
you know what's up she's like you know
what's bigger than a million a bajillion
bajillion abortions in america every
year you know what you know what lauren
bobert if you can hear me
i think i think we should have at least
at least four million abortions in a
year that's what i'm saying yeah
absolutely let's do that you [ __ ]
idiot you are such a [ __ ] bonehead
like
there's there gabe did you know there's
650 million people who die from gun
violence in the united states every
single year 650 million
somehow 650 million it's like just like
that's like double the population here
but yeah
331 million people in this country which
by the way we own 393 million guns in
this right that's an action that's an
actual that's an actual number
when the guns outnumber the people you
know you have a problem
this [ __ ] idiot just absolutely pulls
how many
extra she add
from the original number to get to a
million was it three zeros i don't know
four zeros i have no idea the the
craziest part about this whole thing
it's like
some procedures
um that are
are called abortion procedures right
aren't even
really abortions like there's no life
it's just literally a clump of cells
right
like it literally is a clump of cells
like sometimes an eptopic pregnancy
where they actually take out the the
cells to save a woman's life because
she's it's gonna rupture and she's
possibly gonna die i had a friend of
mine who would not be alive today if
republicans had their way and
you know it saddens me that you have to
[ __ ] explain actual [ __ ] real [ __ ]
to boneheads like this and they still
don't get it because they're like well
there's a million a million get the [ __ ]
out of here now listen to what she says
after this this is oh this is classic
bobo the clown here
one million do you know how many gun
violent deaths there are gun related
deaths there are in america per year
fifteen thousand
hmm
a drop in the bucket i'd say yeah like
19 kids and you you've already just a
drop in the bucket just a drop in the
bucket who gives a [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
just a drop in the butt you are a vile
disgusting pathetic cowardly piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] lauren bobert
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] garbage
claiming to save the children and all
this [ __ ] and then you're like ah those
children and yuvaldi that are stacked up
that they're bot they're they [ __ ]
have to identify them with dna because
their bodies are ripped apart by [ __ ]
guns that you claim you love and you
have your children posed in front of a
christmas tree you piece of [ __ ]
trash you piece of
[ __ ] trash
i i don't even know if there's another
word to describe i used the c word
earlier and i'm not going to continue
this nonsense here but you get you get
the idea how stupid she [ __ ] is
oh just a drop in the butt are you
kidding me
my response to this i tweeted it i said
the dumber the better like literally in
this and right right now the dumber the
[ __ ] idea they can just spew into a
[ __ ] camera the [ __ ] better it is
i feel like a drop in the bucket holy
[ __ ] i have lost
at least 10 to 15 iq points watching the
video of lauren bober try to come up
with some random number about abortions
and come up with a number about gun
related deaths right and then be like
[ __ ] who cares who cares about those
people in buffalo or the people in the
church in california there's that's just
a drop who cares it's just a drop in the
butt don't worry about your children
being killed in schools it's just a drop
in the bucket it's just hey look look
it's for the it's for the it's look it's
it's for it's for the good okay for the
good of humanity okay your kids died so
we could live
that's what she's trying to argue here
right this is the party that wants to
give rights to unborn
women
not unborn men just unborn women
because unborn lives matter right those
lives matter not the actual living
children and the living babies [ __ ]
those kids you know lauren bobert uh
using her words obviously
um
but you you look at this and
this party
wants to excuse the deaths and justify
them to say well in comparison to uh
abortions
it's not really a big deal you know it's
like one here 20 there whatever you know
it's like
could you be worse of a person honestly
could could lauren bobert be any worse
and i and i asked that question and i
know the answer is yes she could because
she will be
she will be
and she will prove it to us at some
point in the near future
she will do something to say oh the bar
wasn't low enough
let me just [ __ ] knock it off the
rack and put it on the ground
oh
she's just straight up a [ __ ]
absolute
bonehead absolute bonehead speaking
speaking of [ __ ] boneheads let's go
to the bonehead of the week here
uh greg abbott the the the disgraced
pathetic governor
of texas who has blood on his hands who
is the reason why
the shooting and you've already killed
19 children and two teachers
um
why we have the traumatic images of
parents trying to barricade past the
armed guards at the school trying to
prevent them from going in to save their
children because they wouldn't because
they're scared of bullets apparently
um
i mean also it's just also completely
understandable that somebody would be
afraid of bullets
you as a human i know that a bullet will
kill you
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna probably
hesitate before i say well you know and
these are people that are trained law
enforcement professionals right whether
they're trained well enough or not
these people are the ones who are
supposed to be out there defending us
they're the ones who actually have the
ability to wear protective armor and
actually have weapons to go against
someone else who has a weapon and even
they
even they don't want to go in
and when they do
it's only to get their own kids because
[ __ ] your kids right my kids matter gabe
the reason why is because these weapons
are designed
to neutralize someone even in body armor
these are weapons of war
like the gun manufacturers are
manufacturing these weapons these
assaults assault style weapons to make
sure that if someone has body armor on
that they can stop them that's the whole
[ __ ] point that's why it rips through
your flesh that's why it tears off your
arms and it makes your head explode if
it hits impact and i'm gonna be graphic
here i want to be graphic i want you to
realize and i i wish
i wish the media
would would would stop showing pictures
of the children that were [ __ ]
that were slaughtered
of them smiling and being great children
and i wish they would show pictures of
their dead [ __ ] bodies maybe that
would [ __ ] change people's minds in
this country not to show the pictures
where they're standing when in school
awards that's dead that's dead and long
gone greg abbott made sure our bonehead
of the week made sure that didn't happen
anymore to that child yeah forget that
[ __ ] picture show them the picture
that everyone needs to [ __ ] see show
them the picture of the main bodies that
this that this [ __ ] 18 year old was a
that greg abbott allowed him with state
law to go buy that weapon to murder and
slaughter and tear apart those children
that's the pictures you should see of
these children
that's the picture you should see of
them
just like emmett till
show them the horror
show them maybe it'll change their
[ __ ] mind probably not some of these
sick bucks like greg abbott and some of
our other boneheads but maybe just maybe
maybe americans will wake up and realize
what the [ __ ] is happening to our
children what the [ __ ] is happening to
our schools what the [ __ ] is happening
to our fellow community members when
they're being shot in churches and
grocery stores i i read a post that
comment the other day
this is how vile this is with with
governors like greg abbott passing some
of these laws one one of our listeners
um commented somewhere
i no longer
wear flip-flops in a grocery store i
only wear tennis shoes
now you say well why would you do that
the reason why is so she can run
think about that if you're planning out
what shoes you're gonna wear to go buy
milk
think about that for a second folks
putting on the right pair of shoes so
you can run from bullets because you got
to go buy milk
you crazy [ __ ] who think this
is not a gun problem
she's not right she's not putting on her
shoes to run from a person
she's running from [ __ ] bullets that
are being flung out of a weapon that is
designed to kill people who have flak
jackets on who have body armor on
and they're killing little children
they're killing innocent people in
grocery stores churches and schools you
[ __ ] pieces of garbage and especially
this [ __ ] piece of garbage greg
abbott now i do want to show
the um
the uh
interaction here between beto
uh and and greg abbott
um you know i do want to say one one one
thing is uh is the idea of
of showing those photos or showing video
it reminds me when i was in driver's ed
and i don't know if they still do this
but i imagine they still do probably
is when they show you
the people that were driving drunk or
got into a car accident because they
didn't wear a seat belt or whatever it
was right and they show you oh this
person [ __ ] went through the window
or this person was drunk and they got
into a you know a an
pile up and this is the body in their
brains spread out across the [ __ ] uh
pavement
though i still remember those images
they are disgusting they are effective
as [ __ ]
right making you remember why you
shouldn't do this because this
might possibly be an outcome for the
dumb decision that you make
well here's the thing and and some
people may say you're crazy you're
absolutely out of your mind to show
people these images
there's a story
of an 11 year old girl
in the robb elementary school
who was cowering next to her friend's
dead [ __ ] body
and to make sure that the gunman didn't
shoot her
she pulled
blood
off the dead body of her friend
and smeared it all over her body and
played dead
so that shooter would think she was dead
and would not fire at her an 11 year old
girl
had to [ __ ] take the blood off her
friend's dead body
when moments before they were
happy
right they were getting ready for their
summer break
they were they were probably they were
probably
excited
about memorial day weekend and the plans
that their families had
and she has to take
and smear
the blood
from
her friend another [ __ ] baby
a little bitty baby
person
and spread it all over her [ __ ] body
to play dead
it is sad and disgusting i mean like you
know we were talking today they had two
days left
two days left of school
those two days i remember them in grade
school those two days are when you're
like helping clean up the classroom and
you're putting away the desks and the
final two days are just basically like
all right we're just gonna play around
we're gonna go on recess we're gonna do
this we're gonna do that because there's
no there's nothing left to do
it's just kind of clean up and have a
fun summer
two days
two [ __ ] days before they were let
out to go run through sprinklers and go
to the pool and and scuff their knees on
the ground
it's [ __ ] gross it's [ __ ] gross
as as gross as uh
the mayor
of uvalde this [ __ ] guy
he almost if people knew who he was i
was gonna put him on a list absolutely
no one would know who this [ __ ] idiot
is no one should know who this idiot is
i don't even think people in the town
know who this guy is unless they've had
to deal with the [ __ ] probably this
guy barely getting across stage to tell
is
he's a [ __ ] vile piece of [ __ ] but
this is the scene and we actually were
playing this uh press this nra press
conference live
um where they're trying to clean up the
mess of what they've done to children in
texas by by allowing 19 students and
yuvaldi to be slaughtered these
politicians that are sitting up here
they're they're to blame for this
and beto decides to tell them to do
their [ __ ] jobs uh there's a meme
going around and it says when you order
thoughts and prayers
but do your job show do your [ __ ] job
shows up and it's a picture of beto
pointing at them and the law enforcement
officers pointing for him to get out but
let's listen to this because watch what
greg abbott doesn't do that's the that
is the most speakable moment of this
entire clip is what he doesn't do watch
what he doesn't do
okay
[Music]
you see what he didn't do game did you
notice that there
you notice he couldn't even look at
bitto
he's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] such a [ __ ]
coward that he wouldn't even turn and
look beto in the eye
i for forget about saying anything to
him no you're not saying anything to him
no no no couldn't even turn to look him
in the [ __ ] eye you got ted
cruz saying like oh get out of here with
the father yeah like the guy he the guy
oh my god ted cruz is a cook okay
also a consideration if he wasn't
already on the list i would have put him
in alphacut because he stood behind that
table and he's like yo get out of here
don't beat your politicizing this
meanwhile i gotta get my thoughts ready
when i talk about this back door problem
right right right
it is ridiculous and there was
he's doing something even coward more
cowardly tonight he won't cancel
on the nra no no
because he bought and [ __ ] pay for he
bought and [ __ ] paid for so he's
gonna phone him in with the [ __ ]
video message what a pile of [ __ ]
[ __ ] i actually think that the video
message is much more cowardly than even
showing up like oh yeah and donald trump
what a [ __ ] coward can't even [ __ ]
beto o'rourke approaches him and says do
your [ __ ] job like a goddamn
man gets belly to belly with this guy to
tell him to do his [ __ ] job
and this guy got a phone in on the nra
because he has to say something because
he's bought and paid for but he can't go
there because he's such a [ __ ] no no he
can't show up there actually is
something you reminded me of something
um
is the
is the gym shoes
not wearing flip-flops but switching out
for gym shoes commercial yeah and i
wanted to play the commercial for
everyone um it it came out after sandy
hook it was for the from the sandy hook
promise which is an organization
and gun violence
um
so let me let me play let me play let's
let's play this real quick and then uh
when we come back we'll give we'll give
the bonus of the week greg abbott his
due but this this should tell you why
greg abbott as governor is a bonehead
and you should vote him the [ __ ] out
this year my mom got me the perfect bag
for back to school
these chemical binders help me stay
organized
these headphones are just what i need
for studying
these new sneakers are just what i need
for the new year
this jacket is a real must-have my
parents got me the skateboard i wanted
it's pretty cool
[Music]
these scissors really come in handy in
art class
these colored pencils too
these new socks
they can be a real lifesaver
[Music]
i finally got my own phone to stay in
touch with my mom
[Music]
[Music]
sandyhookpromise.org with that ad
i don't know how old that is it's
several years old now but um
if you if you've if you've got
anything to give um at all just a couple
pennies a couple dollars
um don't forget some of these
organizations out there that are working
really hard
um
that are
in the fight and make politics out of
this issue because it should be politics
it is about policy it is about having
common sense policy in this country to
save our children save our community
members our friends our colleagues lives
from this absolute [ __ ] nonsense that
we have to go through every day in this
country because of [ __ ] pieces of
[ __ ] like this
because of greg abbott the bonehead of
the week this [ __ ]
let's give him his due
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well there you have it greg abbott
bonehead of the week bonehead of the
month bonehead of the year whatever you
want to give him him and the rest of the
gop with the blood on their hands
folks i've said it all week you need to
become one issue voters and one issue
only and that is vote them the [ __ ] out
[ __ ] you the gop that is your one issue
[ __ ] the g.o.p [ __ ] em [ __ ] you greg
abbott and [ __ ] anyone who's like you
folks that's the bonehead of the week
it's been a it's been a hard week here
you have a great memorial day weekend
but stick around we have a few
announcements right after the song
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]